so everybody charge is a Russian so far
no votes were changed although some were
perpetrated so where is the supposed
Russian collusion as of yet Dan banjee
knows all over this investigative his
investigative skills without peer
he's a former Secret Service agent
himself NRA TV contributor where and of
course we love having him on dan what
did you learn from today well I read
through the indictment Brian there are a
couple of key takeaways number one as
Charlie said he's absolutely correct
it's clear as day now there are two
parallel tracks and the Sam part is
these tracks are starting there's some
cross contamination going on here
here's track number one that has
bipartisan agreement we all agree the
Russians are not our friends they tried
to tamper with the election the
indictment is very detailed and it's
very substantive it details a
spearfishing operation by Russian GRU
members to try to steal data from some
Democrats and infiltrate some potential
Republicans and the lobbyists and
members of the press that's that's fine
we're all in agreement the Russians are
not our friends the problem is there's
no collusion Brian we've been told for
what almost two years now
that somehow Trump colluded with the
Russians or his team members to alter
the results of the election and there is
still absolutely zero evidence of that
whatsoever and it is bogging down our
political process so there's a big call
among some leadership some of the
leadership on the Democratic side of the
president in light of this information
to not meet with Vladimir Putin would
that be a good move Dan now why should
he not meet with him you know I don't
understand I never get I can't figure
out Democrats for the life of me you
know they debate themselves all the time
on issues they had absolutely no problem
this is not what about ISM it's about
principles right when Barack Obama met
with met with Cuban representatives down
in Cuba they had no issue with that but
now we know Donald Trump has information
he can confront Putin with about
documented Soviet military
excuse me Russian military members
excuse me and we'll talk about a
Freudian slip right trying to infiltrate
our election process and they want him
to call off the meeting
that's absurd that's ridiculous this is
actually the perfect opportunity to hit
Putin on it do you believe damn Bungie
know that they're gonna try it again
this midterm
of course I mean these are this is our
main geopolitical foe I mean this is a
nuclear powered nation that's figured
out a long time a time ago that if they
can so domestic chaos they can rip the
United States apart from within and
that's the problem Brian I have with
these parallel tracks there's one
credible investigation and this garbage
Trump Russian collusion investigation
which it's it's a it's a house of sand
there's nothing there the Democrats need
to just let this thing go and focus on
the real enemy which is the Russian part
of the infiltration dan you're not the
real enemy you're a real friend of the
show in the network thanks so much
thanks pal